[Music]
if we can't hug a second she's my girl
the Barden Bellas an unlikely group of
not men who somehow managed to win it
something that didn't have to do with
baking I can hear you they graduated
college express their wings and are
attempting to fly the five layers
delight with a shot of white privilege
hopefully not becoming failures we all
expect them to be it'll really good
about where I'm at right now I'm trying
to get into vet school
fingers crossed where are they now
my name is fat Amy Winehouse so let's
get crackin I quit my job
you got fun no I quit it's fine reaction
I would do anything to sing with you
guys again anything you guys every year
the USO puts on this performance to
support the troops in Europe what if I
could get us an invite
yeah I've suddenly got a bunch of free
time so hell yeah
it's my
guys we've never competed against bands
that actually have instruments so what's
the plan coming up I'm coming out oh you
guys just sing other people's songs like
karaoke Carrie oh that's so cute in
calamity this is serenity Brasserie and
charity if I joined your group I could
be a BCT
another day on stage for the Bellas this
is their big plummet their fade out into
nothingness Fisher with us have I ever
let you down all the time wha
you're very unreliable it's like one of
the hallmarks of your personality you're
not remembering all the times I've been
awesome
let's haka finish this
I love you want some nerds stop
[Music]
try to have some dignity
yeah well we don't do anything with
dignity okay they really do need to join
the workforce yes
[Music]